Hey, my name is Eric, and I'll
be co-presenting with Monsur.
So what
we'll be talking about--
first I'm going to be
giving you an introduction
to Oauth.
So for those
who aren't familiar,
Oauth is an open standard
for authorizing
data access on the web,
sharing users' private data.
We'll be going into a little bit
about the details of the app,
but mainly focusing on how that
incorporates into a gadget.
Next thing
we'll be talking about
is OpenSocial.
So in the case of iGoogle,
you can create a really
interesting OpenSocial gadget
using Oauth
to access a user's
private calendar data,
Blogger data,
contacts, what have you
with the Google Data APIs.
Lastly, we're going
to go into the Google Data
JavaScript client library,
which is a great J.S. library
for reading and writing
data on the web.
It makes OpenSocial gadgets
particularly easy.
So here's some skeleton code
that's sort of--
we're going to explain
about the Oauth flow.
The Oauth flow actually,
in iGoogle,
involves a pop-up window,
and that gives
the user the ability
to grant or deny
access to the data.
So the first thing they see
when they come to iGoogle
is this
"Sign in to Blogger"
in this example gadget.
We've created an OnClick
handler for that.
And so when they click that,
this pop-up window
pops up--
this is a Google page,
and they are choosing
or denying access
to their Blogger data.
And so if they choose
to grant access,
the gadget
will refresh itself.
And last but not least,
this is the normal state
of the gadget.
The gadget's
been authenticated.
The token is registered
in the O/I proxy,
and you can post away
to Blogger via iGoogle,
which is really cool.
We'll talk about how
to do this in OpenSocial
and then how much easier it is
actually using the G-Data
JavaScript client library.
So I hope to see you there.
We'll be at Google I/O
in May.